I am sending you an invoice for the 9
000 boxes of tissues that I went through
as I binged part one of season two of
firefly Lane that was our goal so I want
to just jump right in on a sad note
Kate's Health that was really emotional
for me to watch the rash on your breast
is actually a rare and very aggressive
form of cancer treatment right away it
was really emotional there's nobody
whose lives have not been touched by
cancer
we lost my aunt my grandmother to cancer
there were crew members who came up to
me and told me their stories so when
you're shooting and you become very
close with this crew and you're looking
into the eyes of those people as you're
doing that scene
um yeah it was definitely it was a lot
of you know heavy
days there that last few weeks of
filming
is Kate gonna be okay
oh I can't answer that I can't answer
that you'll have to watch season two
part two which is gonna come out next
year okay um we've actually shot all of
it okay so so you know so you know how
it is I know I know all of the things
and um but that is uh something that
plays out yeah through the last half of
the Season yeah I was gonna say how does
this health Journey that she's about to
go on how does it shape the next part of
season two it really does
um it really does and I think
again you know it's such a fine you know
just threading the needle of how to tell
the story
um
have the balance of what's happening in
the 70s the 80s we go into the 90s a
bunch
um and then obviously in the Arts and uh
so yeah that's all I
think I know that Kate and Tully are not
exactly on speaking terms where we stand
present day but I'm hopeful that as Kate
goes on this journey she will have the
aid of her BFF you know through it all
should we remain hopeful
I mean I always think I mean that's how
I walk through life is remaining hopeful
there's like the mini Cliffhangers that
happen sort of throughout the season so
you're constantly like going like oh
another big moment that happens at the
end of part one of season two yeah we
see the girls well at least Kate finally
gets to a place where she's like ready
to reconcile totally either
[Music]
are they going have that moment of of
reconnecting what I loved about that in
the end of the season was like as much
as has come between them
um
that when you know really hits the fan
she just needs Tully and kind of like
obviously everything else melts away and
she goes to her and then
she's not there
I thought so much about like okay what
is it going to be what could this
possibly be that Tully did that is big
enough
to break this like unbelievably
unbreakable Bond of this friendship so
what could it possibly be that would do
that but that also
has the possibility
of you know them coming back together in
the future I'm sorry
I am truly
why wasn't that apology enough for Kate
I think it's a big deal and Kate wants
to forgive her so badly because
obviously she wants her back in her life
so badly but it was just it was just
crossing the line it was too much and
then on the flip side of it like I think
you know
it was like Tully because of her past
and because
everything that happened in season one
with Pat like it just triggers for her
the second she hears Mara's voice on the
phone and you know that she's just like
drop everything let's go I have to I
just have to go to her right now and she
forgets about anything and everything
else I think you really feel for that
and you really see that side of it too
so what I loved about the decision was
that it was something that you could
really see
both sides of it and relate to both of
them and understand both of them and
really see where both of them were
coming from will things get better in
part two there's
a lot of challenging stuff we filmed
there's a lot of really fun stuff
there's some I mean the show always gets
you outside of your comfort zone like
there's never you're never safe inside
your lips there's no safe space every
time you open the script you're like oh
that's what we're doing I want to talk
about something else that brings a smile
to my face okay the idea of of Tully and
Danny may be getting together have a
nice trip to Lula Rose
I'll be thinking about you
you will yeah
I usually do
have we seen the last of those two it
was kind of like I think unexpected you
know for Tully's character you know just
kind of caught off guard like who is
this
person and why do I like them so much
and she starts to let her guard down in
ways that you know she really
never has they still you know I think
can intellectually Spar and have such
chemistry and more than anyone else that
they have with anyone else in their
lives right okay so should we remain
optimistic that that door is not closed
yeah he definitely he continues through
so we'll see what happens okay yeah and
then more good news on the love front
Kate is an Engaged woman yes
congratulations thank you very much how
do we go into season two are we gonna
see wedding planning will we get a
wedding
there might be there might be some
planning there might be some dresses
that we got to wear I don't know
um but um I don't know I don't know how
it's going to turn out okay yeah oh that
that doesn't make me feel good because
in my opinion their end game I like my
Johnny with my Kate I think they make
sense together they worked through all
their issues they did the hard work and
now you get to reap the benefits you get
to be engaged and hopefully make it to
the altar yeah what do you think are
they an end game couple I I mean I
believe in love I've kind of hoped from
the beginning that they would be yeah
um but uh you know you uh you never know
right so many twists and turns I know
you can't say a whole lot about part two
of season two yeah but what is the most
exciting question that all the fans have
that you're most excited to answer how
do all of the love stories roll out okay
so we can expect a lot of people you can
get spec and you can special a lot of
answers is there one specific storyline
that you can tease you're just really
excited for the fans to see what happens
with Kate's Journey with Her diagnosis I
want everyone to sort of get to see what
happens there and um and then uh
yeah and then also just to see the
obviously the through line of Kate and
Johnny and what happens with them I mean
my goodness how is how is Johnny gonna
be a support to her as she goes on this
very challenging journey ahead yeah
yeah you'll have to see we'll have to
tune in okay got you're good at your job
you're good at signing contracts and
staying true to them on a scale of one
to ten yeah how emotional is part two of
season two going to be
oh very yeah like 10 we're tipping the
scale yeah I think so I think it's ten
you think it's a ten yeah I think it's a
10. okay can you describe part two of
season two in three adjectives it's
funny and it's painful and
um
and moving I was quite moved when I read
it yeah yeah oh gosh so even you get
emotional oh like I I got emotional
reading it because yeah you play these
characters you get attached to to them
oh my goodness well you know it pains me
because it is such a show that we have
really grown so attached to yeah but it
is the end and so for you as an actress
going to work knowing we're doing season
two and it's gonna be our last did it
feel different going to work oh
absolutely that was definitely though
towards the end like oh there was a lot
of Tears the last week of shooting and
you know just sort of especially the
last day it was so surreal you know just
knowing that like oh this is gonna be it
who cried the most
um I think it might have been a tie I
think we all did
and the crew too it was like it was
really it was special right like I think
there's a not it's not every day
that you have a job like that you know
where it's a bit of a unicorn experience
where all the pieces kind of come
together you just called this show
Firefly Lane a unicorn project yeah I
can see the joy in your eyes and your
face when you talk about it it's a
runaway hit I have some research here
over the course of at least season one
the 10 episode run it pulled in more
than 1.3 billion minutes of viewing
beating out very very popular other
shows so it begs my question at least
why is it ending
well I I mean as far as I know like that
was I mean from the beginning when we
had all spoken about it this is about
the number of episodes that it arcs out
over like the it does follow the story
of the book and so by the time
you get to the end of the story like the
story is told so this was always the
plan it was kind of the plan like to it
was a you know we did 10 episodes the
first season and then there was these
two chunks and it kind of naturally
follows the course of that so the nice
part of that is that
um it allows the full story to be told
you're not kind of waiting and then it
ends on kind of like a weird note but um
but it's sad to that it's done if there
was an opportunity to kind of Game of
Thrones it and you know go beyond the
books and create a whole new chapter
ahead for Tully and for Kate I mean
would you be interested in extending
because it seems like you had the time
of your life I absolutely had the time
of my life and everybody did like we all
you know it was one of those things
where like nobody uh nobody wanted to
end okay so if if there was a chance to
extend it I I mean yes of course but I
think this is I think this is like the
story the story gets told
[Music]